el 25 de mayo de 2020 Mineápolis se
encendió tras la muerte de George Floyd
una afroamericano de 46 años asesinado
por la policía este edificio estaba en
llamas había muchas personas ahí y aquí
también
los policías estaban en el techo y
disparaban a la gente
al unísono los estadounidenses
protestaban en contra del racismo
sistemático después de haber presenciado
los 8 minutos y 46 segundos de agonía
este video grabado por una joven testigo
de la escena le dio la vuelta al mundo y
generó semanas de protestas en Estados
Unidos
tres años después las fachadas de este
barrio de Minneapolis todavía dan cuenta
de ese momento
este es uno de los lugares más
importantes en la historia de los
derechos de los afroamericanos
si esta estación de policía no se
hubiera incendiado Derek Shelby no
habría sido condenado y la familia de
George Floyd no habría obtenido justicia
fue condenado a más de 22 años de cárcel
por el asesinato de George Floyd y la
ciudad de Mineápolis pagó 27 millones de
dólares de indemnización a la familia de
la afroamericano
pero para traer un crews la lucha no ha
terminado piensa que es necesario
reformar profundamente las políticas
públicas y poner en marcha el proceso de
reparación Para los afroamericanos
Minnesota es el tercer estado con la
mayor disparidad económica entre sus
comunidades en el país y aún así los
ingresos del Estado son superiores a los
gastos públicos hay 10.000 millones de
excedente nosotros pensamos en que el
dinero Debería ser utilizado para
iniciar el proceso de reparación no es
suficiente que nuestro representante
selectos vengan a Un entierro nos digan
que entienden nuestro dolor necesitamos
que hagan algo concreto
desde mayo de 2020 se han cambiado los
nombres de algunas calles y centros
educativos y han sido reemplazados por
los de personajes afroamericanos además
en todo el país se han derribado
estatuas de soldados confederados
actualmente se siguen eriendo nuevos
monumentos y el nombre de George Floyd
ahora está junto al de los militantes
por los derechos civiles es un monumento
que estará aquí por siempre
es un reconocimiento que permite
mantener vivo su nombre y eso me hace
sentir muy orgulloso
Roger es el tío paterno de George Floyd
Todavía vive en Carolina del Norte lugar
de origen de la familia
cuando era niño él soñaba con ser famoso
pero seguramente No de esta manera
creó una fundación para ayudar a los
afroamericanos que lo necesitan pero
tres años después de la muerte de su
sobrino él también lamenta que los
cambios sociales hayan sido
superficiales creo que la muerte de
George Floyd despertó al mundo
ahora las personas son más conscientes
pero es como ir a una manifestación
en el momento las personas están
conmovidas y determinadas
pero cuando todo se acaba regresan a sus
casas y no vuelven a hacer nada hasta
que ocurre la siguiente tragedia
eso tiene que cambiar
la muerte de George Floyd tuvo un
impacto particular en la generación
joven preocupada por construir una
sociedad más tolerante y justa en Howard
una de las 107 universidades
históricamente negras de Estados Unidos
este profesor de derecho insiste en la
importancia de crear élites
afroamericanas
durante mucho tiempo el acceso a la
educación en Estados Unidos estuvo
separado entre negros y blancos
pero nuestras universidades negras
permitieron que las comunidades de
esclavizados que habían sido liberados
hicieran estudios superiores
y les dieron la posibilidad de tener un
rol económico y político
hoy en día todavía seguimos desempeñando
ese papel esencial
un papel que este profesor considera aún
más importante ahora que los programas
de diversidad e inclusión están en
riesgo en las universidades públicas de
varios estados republicanos hablar sobre
relaciones raciales ya era difícil pero
ahora hay lugares en los que se está
volviendo prácticamente imposible porque
se están implementando leyes y políticas
para prohibir que se hable sobre eso
como si mencionarlo fuera problemático
es una las consecuencias más
decepcionantes que he visto desde el
asesinato de George
floydney Washington Siri está en segundo
año de derecho tenía 23 años cuando
murió George Floyd Y recuerda haber
sentido la responsabilidad de hacer un
cambio en su país
como miembros de la comunidad negra eso
nos llevó a preguntarnos sobre la
estrategia que queríamos adoptar sobre
cómo podíamos aprovechar ese momento Y
tratar de que no solo fuera pasajero
es nuestro trabajo asegurarnos que la
Consigna de Black lives matter no se
quede solo en palabras y que las
escuelas las organizaciones y los grupos
políticos mantengan sus compromisos
no queremos dejar nuestra generación tal
y como la encontramos
una generación es lo mínimo que se
necesitará para ver un cambio en Estados
Unidos después de tres años y de un
contundente informe del Ministerio de
derechos humanos de Minnesota la ciudad
de Mineápolis Por fin se comprometió a
hacer una reforma estructural de su
institución policial en Estados Unidos
los hombres negros tienen tres veces más
posibilidades de ser asesinados por la
policía